SENATE FLOOR EVEN THOUGH COONS
OPPOSES IT.
FULL SENATE VOTE.
POMPEO HAS ENOUGH VOTES AS OF
TONIGHT TO BE CONFIRMED.
IN WEEKS, PRESIDENT TRUMP
ET CETERA MEET FACE-TO-FACE WITH
NORTH KOREAN LEADER KIM JONG UN,
AND IS BOTH SIDES READY FOR THE
HISTORIC MEETING,
CONCESSIONS ARE ALREADY BEING
MADE.
GILLIAN TURNER REPORTS.
>> RIGHT NOW I THINK THERE'S A
LOT OF REASONS FOR OPTIMISM.
>> TRUMP ADMINISTRATION IS
GEARING UP TO FACE OFF AGAINST
KIM JONG UN IN A FEW WEEKS.
THE FIRST TIME AN AMERICAN
PRESIDENT HAS AGREED TO MEET
WITH THE HEAD OF THE
NORTH KOREAN REGIME.
SOUTH AND NORTH KOREAN LEADERS
PLAN TO MEET FRIDAY TO HAMMER
OUT GROUND RULES FOR THE SUMMIT.
IN WASHINGTON, LASER FOCUSED ON
THE OUTCOME OF THE INTERIM
MEETING.
SOME SENIOR LAWMAKERS OFFERING
ADVICE.
>> IT'S BEEN GOING ON FOR 25
YEARS.
OBVIOUSLY KIM JONG UN HAS
LEARNED ABOUT PUBLIC RELATIONS
AND IS SETTING UP WELL.
>> KIM HAS ANNOUNCED MAJOR
CONCESSIONS OVER THE WEEKEND.
IN THE PAST, THE INTERNATIONAL
COMMUNITY AND WOULD'VE DEEMED IT
IMPOSSIBLE.
THE NORTH SAYS IT WILL CEASE
NUCLEAR TESTING.
CLOSE A NUCLEAR TESTING SITE AS
A GUARANTEE OF TRANSPARENCY AND
KIM FLOATED THE POSSIBILITY OF
RELEASING THREE LONG-HELD
AMERICAN HOSTAGES.
TODAY A BRAND-NEW CONCESSION
FROM THE SOUTH KOREANS IN
RETURN.
THEY HAVE SILENCED THE
LOUDSPEAKERS THAT PUMPED
ANTI-NORTH MESSAGING FOR TWO
YEARS.
>> THIS SOUND YOU HEAR HIS
SOUTH KOREAN MUSIC, PROPAGANDA
BEING BLASTED INTO NORTH KOREA.
NORTH KOREA OVER MY SHOULDER.
THE MOUNTAINS, IT'S ESTIMATED
NORTH KOREA HAS 1500 ARTILLERY
PIECES POSITIONED IN THOSE
MOUNTAINS.
>> ADDING UP TO WHAT MAY BE A
MAJOR DIPLOMATIC SAW THAT SEEMED
IMPOSSIBLE.
ADMINISTRATION OFFICIALS SAY
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS FOCUSED ON
SETTING UP PRECONDITIONS FOR
KIM.
THEY SAY HE WANTS KIM TO
DISMANTLE HIS NUCLEAR PROGRAM
BEFORE THE U.S. COMMITS TO ANY
SANCTIONS.
KEEP IN MIND PRESIDENT TRUMP AS
MANY POINTS OF CONTENTION WITH
PRESIDENT OBAMA'S NUCLEAR DEAL.
HIS MAIN CRITICISM HAS LONG BEEN
THAT THE OBAMA TEAM MISSED AN
OPPORTUNITY TO DEMAND
CONCESSIONS FROM IRAN BEFORE